so i guess i'm going to talk about
decisions and economics and those are
two topics i know very little about
together i'll know something about them
so this is a fairly standard view of
economics we have a collection of agents
or people that are selfish not in the
sense that they're necessarily egotistic
but in the sense that they each agent
follows are their own agenda and they
create and allocate and exchange various
limited resources and it's a standard
assumption in economics that when you
view such a system it is in it is
normally in some state of equilibrium
that are not going to specify precisely
here at the moment but at least most of
the time this is the way it seems to
people who observe it now the system is
an enormous distributed system in the
sense that the control of the system is
given to these agents they have local
knowledge so knowledge is also
distributed in this system they don't
unlike our classical distributed systems
in computer science they're not
engineered to follow any common goal so
the system is not engineered in the
spirit of this morning's talk we are
taking here a scientific view and not a
engineering view of what we're doing and
the question that or the focus of this
talk is about is the following natural
questions so how is such a system driven
to seem to be in the state of
equilibrium when there
no overall control or no engineering
that actually forces is to be in the
state of equilibrium so that's one
question that we could ask about such a
system what kind so this is not a
question of what how to make decisions
it's a question of what are plausible
this decisions of the agents that lead
the system to a state of equilibrium and
of course since economic systems are not
really stable they change over time and
sometimes they there are some drastic
changes a natural question or an a
natural follow-up question is how is
equilibrium restored when the system is
driven out of the equilibrium so these
are obviously questions about the
dynamics or the stability of the system
and our goal is to search for plausible
reasons why why equilibrium exists in
these systems so I'm going to talk a
little bit about various approaches to
this question so in game theory dynamics
are usually mean that we have some
underlying game that's the stage game
and the agent simply play this game
repeatedly so they play the same game
again and again and but they know
they're going to play it again and again
so so they can design their actions in
view of the fact that they're going to
play this game indefinitely and this is
how game theory views dynamics so are
the
theoretical you simply produces a longer
game that this this repeated game is
just a longer game that has more
available strategies and then game
theory designed all sorts of solution
concepts that are supposed to capture
the behavior of agents under the
incentives that the game produces for
them so normally in in these situations
what game theorists look at our are
these extensive form equilibria their
various sorts of them I'm not going to
go into their details things like a sub
game perfect equilibria and or or or
sequential equilibria and various other
notions of equilibrium so very generally
speaking the idea there is that the
agents actually compute in advance all
the optimal moves for all possible
situations of the system and all
possible visible actions of the other
agents and and then they they play
basically their best strategy taking
into account all the possibilities of
the game so in fact these equilibria
notions are actually a static notion
because you unravel the entire evolution
of the game in advance and play
optimally against that taking into
account of course what the other players
will do and this poses several problems
to our goal so first technical problem
is that these solutions are often
intractable so in fact it's not clear
how agents would actually come about to
play
because they can't that they can't
compute them efficiently as far as we
know it also requires players to be
unrealistically prescient so they
actually need to know or they need to
think about what will happen in this
game forever and it's actually
surprising that most economists view the
economy is behaving this way so the
current state of the economy actually is
assumed to take into account all
possible eventualities of what will
happen in the future and to incorporate
all that in the current equilibrium and
of course if you're unrealistically
prescient it's very hard for you to
adapt to unexpected changes of the
economy so in this respect this is
unrealistic because players normally
would take into account the fact that
the economy will at some point change in
ways that they can't currently predict
so what would we want to have from a
more realistic dynamic view of an
economic system well it would be nice to
have all sorts of things so so here is a
list of them we want the decisions or
the moves of the agents to have some
empirical evidence that this is actually
what what people do under these
circumstances we want to have some
justification for these move so we want
some some form of rationality or of
rational decision-making by the agents
they're not completely that the model
should have some justification for these
moves now this might be a bit more
debatable but this is something it seems
reasonable is that the agents themselves
are there's no particular reason for
them to aim for equilibrium they are
trying to achieve their own goals their
own agenda so often in what I will
describe moves are or or or certain
dynamics that were suggested actually
very carefully damped the moves in order
to achieve equilibrium and that doesn't
seem to be like a good model that
explains how equilibrium comes about
because it basically makes decisions
directed towards achieving equilibrium
rather than being motivated by what yes
ruling out the stunted cause this kind
of day offs
damn thing is that exam I'm not talking
about any specific model right now but
just in very general so so yes I i would
i might even rule out discount at all
discounted payoffs in the repeated game
for that reason but i'll talk about it a
bit more precisely in the next slide
what i actually mean here in general i
mean here that it doesn't seem a
decision process that aims at
equilibrium doesn't seem to be a
reasonable explanation of how
equilibrium comes about i mean it's it's
a good engineering practice perhaps but
it's not a good explanation and of
course some we want to see that you know
these decisions processes that we model
lead to some attractive outcome or some
some form of equilibrium it they
converge to that and they converge to
that quickly and the reason we we hope
to see quick convergence is exactly this
last point that we should expect because
when we view the economy it's it's
normally in equilibrium we expect it to
and the economy itself of course the
conditions change all the time this
quick convergence is is is almost a
requirement for the economy to follow
equilibrium over a long period of time
or to follow it you normal usually
you're normally over a long period of
time so as soon as conditions change we
expect the economy to move to the new
equilibrium rather quickly otherwise we
will see long periods of time where the
economy is out of equilibrium
okay so there's a whole so other than
these are extensive form equilibria
there's a whole different notion of
dynamics and game theory and and in in
economics in general that fall under
this rubric of learning dynamic so there
are various forms of them I'll only
meant there some of the mentioned here
and I'll go over even fewer of the ones
mentioned here so one rather attractive
kind of dynamics are these are no regret
dynamics we know them in computer
science has essentially multiplicative
weights even though they could be more
general than that they're known to
converge in any game in any stage game
to a correlate to something called a
correlated equilibrium doesn't really
matter what it means right now so so
they suffer from this problem that first
of all it's not known how to implement
them for all games but in cases where
there they are implemented the reactions
of the agents have to be rather
carefully adjusted so that they achieve
this no regret guarantee and this seems
to lack any strategic justification so
it's not clear even that if you know
that everybody is playing a no regret
dynamic that this is what you should
follow maybe you should do something
else they provide some guarantee but
it's not clear why agents should should
do this thing there's sort of a very
myopic version of learning dynamics that
does seem to have some sort of
justification in certain cases this is
best response so best responsibly means
that if I'm in in some situation
i optimize my next step and this is the
exact opposite of these extensive form
equilibria so I'm just looking at the
next step I'm not looking any distance
into the future and I'm optimizing that
and so this is a one form of bounded
rationality I have very limited
foresight I I just try to optimize my
next step and the problem with this of
course is that it's not clear that it
leads to any desirable outcome in fact
in many cases it doesn't but in some
cases it does so it's known to lead to
some form of equilibrium in in some
cases but not in all cases there are all
sorts of other forms that i won't go
into this is a damped version of best
response for instance the thing that
will interest us mostly in in this talk
is this level K model which is almost
the same as a receding horizon control
and control theory so the idea here is
is the following we we have a limited
look ahead so so we we look ahead only K
steps of the game worth most K steps of
the game and then we we basically
optimize that and and and that will be a
response so this kind of behavior has a
certain has some empirical evidence so
there there have been a lot of
experiments on people playing games and
this is the kind of strategy that they
tend to choose that we know for instance
that when you I mean this is something
just folklore knowledge that when you
play chess you you try to you can't
compute all the steps ahead but you try
to compute a few steps ahead and put and
maybe prune some of them and and this
seems to be a way that people play games
in general and it also has some relation
to
various forms of learning of games that
i won't go into so so it's something
that has some at least initial
justification to look into so we're
going to study these things in the very
and a rather restricted setting we're
going to study them in fisher markets
and these are fisher markets this is the
model we have em perfectly divisible
goods that means you can buy any
quantity of them any fractional quantity
of them and we will assume that each of
these goods is owned by a single seller
so so that is one side of the market
each each good has a one seller that is
selling it because they are perfectly
divisible we can scale the quantity in
the market to be one for all the goods
and the demand is generated by n buyers
we won't really be concerned about the
individuality of the buyer so so the
game that we will look into is is is the
seller side so there n buyers are each
buyer has a budget and has some concave
utility function and there J so they're
looking to buy their best basket of
goods based on the utility function but
subject to the budget constraint that
they have now here is more precisely how
demand is generated every good j has
some price varying price pj and the game
that we will look into is how these
prices are set every buyer has a budget
so buyer i has a budget bi and it has a
utility function you I of X i where X I
is a is simply a basket of goods that
this buyer buys so for every possible
combination of goods the buyer has a
utility function UI and UI is assumed to
be concave here
xij is the quantity of good J that buyer
I is buying now the demand that Exxon
that I generate is the basket it
generates the maximum utility subject to
the constraint that the cost of this
basket is bounded by the budget and of
course the demand for good J at prices p
is simply the aggregate demand for all
the buyers for that for that good now
adding at equilibrium it that this is a
the standard notion of market
equilibrium so so equilibrium is
achieved by a price vector P star for
which the demand that the aggregate
demand for each of the goods is exactly
one is exactly the supply so so so will
the equilibrium notion that we're using
here is that the market clear supply
equals demand and in in the setting that
we will consider P star is going to be
unique but this is not necessarily
generally the case we also need the
notion of elasticity of demand so
elasticity of demand simply measures the
percentage of change in demand as a
function of the percentage of change in
the price and you can talk about the
only elasticity so how the demand for j
is affected by its own price and you can
talk about cross elasticity which is how
the demand for j is affected by the
prices of other goods and we're going to
assume the following assumptions i'll
call this elastic and bounded demand
we're assuming that all the cross price
elasticity czar at least 0 this means
that these are
the demand is we grow substitutes which
means that raising the price for good k
cannot decrease the demand for good J
and the own price elasticity czar less
than minus 1 this implies and or is
equivalent to saying that each seller
has an incentive to clear the market no
matter what the other prices are clear
the market for the good that they're
holding otherwise if this doesn't hold
then sellers have an incentive to raise
the price and have the demand be less
than the supply and we're also going to
assume some that prices are bounded so
so if all the prices are very low all
the demands are going to be bigger than
one and if all the prices are very big
then all the demands are going to be
less than 1 so these are the assumptions
that we're going to make now about price
updates so we're going to think of a
repeated game of sorts where in each
round new prices are announced and and
then the sellers observe the demand that
these new prices create and you can
think of this in in in various settings
so in the synchronous setting all prices
are modified simultaneously in
synchronous rounds and and we observe
everything simultaneously in in in the
nascent krinar setting maybe some of the
price or so so each prices is updated at
its own rate which means that at any
given point in time we may observe only
some updates but not all of them and
then there is this more elaborate and I
think most promising model but I'm not
going to talk about it here of ongoing
markets that Colin Fleischer introduced
where I think this actually might
explain equilibrium in the best way in
in this model not only the price updates
are asynchronous but also the market
signals are arbitrarily but bounded Lee
delayed so so you don't actually act
upon fresh information but the
information could be in in one side or
on both sides so so both price
information and demand information may
be somewhat delayed and I think this
actually is is the most promising
direction in explaining yes it delay
differently for different wires and so's
ya so it's delayed differently for
different yes but but there is some
let's say some bound on on the amount of
delay and and it's arbitrary it's not a
fixed delay so I think actually these
delays might be important in explaining
how dynamically a market reaches
equilibrium rather than this
instantaneous view of so so there's a
classical process that seems to explain
the equilibrium specifically in in this
setting it's known to explain
equilibrium and that's proportional to
tone man so so the original process by
walrus which was not very concrete and
the more concrete version of sammelsohn
were both in continuous time so they
were essentially talking about
differential equations but we will
discuss discrete-time Titone meant and
this is how the Skreet time tetona looks
like so basically what you do is what
you would naturally do if there is
excess demand you would raise your price
and if there's excess supply you would
lower your price and specifically
discrete time proportional to torment or
one version of it
looks like this there are some empirical
evidence from experiments that in fact
this is how people update prices in
markets these are a small-scale
experiments so it's not clear that they
reflect what actually happens in a real
market but there is some rather
extensive evidence that this much is
what might happen and what's interesting
is that this seems to happen even in
cases where the atonement does not
convert to an equilibrium there are such
cases not the one not the type of
markets I'm talking about here but there
are cases where this might happen it's
known to converging in various settings
but again we have this problem that the
process does not seem natural in the
sense that it requires careful damping
for it to work and to converge to
equilibrium and and this is just a
picture that about these CS utilities
versus our restriction so so there is an
overlapping region but they're not
identical and none includes the other ok
so we discussed best response so what is
best response here well best response
simply means the following thing each
seller J acts as follows it assumes that
all the other prices are going to stay
put in the next iteration and then it
updates its own price to optimize its
revenue given the assumption that the
other prices are not going to change and
under our own price elasticity
assumption this simply means that a
buyer we assume here that the sellers
know everything about the market they
know all the utility functions so they
can actually calculate this so so this
simply means that buyer Jay is going to
choose a price that clears its own good
yes
why they want to clear them isn't it
possible that they don't sell everything
they actually might get a better revenue
that's exactly why we're making this
this assumption implies that yeah if
that assumption isn't true then this is
not true either than they want to raise
their price as much as possible yeah
yeah yeah I mean this is exactly what
this assumption means now of course it's
not always true what is the general
theory about the existence of market
clearing prices for fishing markets as
it is you this kind of day exist they
always exist market clearing prices
always exist but they're not necessarily
justified by the incentives of the
sellers if each at sellers is a monopoly
over its own good
so there's a difference between
marketing equilibrium and and the issue
of how the sellers will react in terms
of their incentives I guess I can take a
couple of extra minutes okay sure so so
here is a more complicated view we want
to think of sellers so in in in the in
the best response case each seller has a
belief that the other sellers are not
going to change their prices and we want
to think about sellers that have more
complicated beliefs about what will
happen in the next step so here is a
more general form of making beliefs each
seller J will form beliefs about all the
other sellers and these will be labeled
by levels so so the level 0 a level 0
belief is exactly what we discussed
before it's just a belief that the other
sellers are not going to change their
prices or that the other seller s is not
going to change its price a level one
belief is it's either a level 0 belief
or a belief that a seller s will best
respond to level 0 beliefs of the other
agents and in general a level K belief
is that a 44 seller GF is that seller s
will best respond to level less than K
beliefs about the other about all the
other sellers so the dynamic that we now
want to consider is that is is is that
we want to think about each seller our
best responding to some level k belief
about every other seller and we want to
see where that leads us
so this is our main theorem it says the
follow it says in fact something more
general than than what I just described
it tells us that if we have any price
update and this price update satisfies
these four very simple properties are
that i'll skip the definition because of
lack of time so if it's monotone
strictly sub homogeneous and bounded
actually I guess it's just three
properties but we need the fourth
property for convergence then it is a
strict contraction under some metric on
on prices which is this Thompson metric
that's defined here now I'll skip the
actual definitions but what's important
is the consequence so one of the
consequences is that if we have a
dynamic where we're in each step we're
applying such a price update they don't
have to be the same price updates but in
each step we're applying such a price
update which is monotone strictly sub
homogeneous and bounded then this system
converges to equilibrium very quickly so
it's a linear convergence to equilibrium
which means that we're exponentially
fast converging to the equilibrium and
this is true under the Thompson metric
and also under I'll infinity or l2
metrics this is that anything to do with
the levels yeah yeah let me this this
will be the next step so now we consider
a dynamic where in each step every
seller is responding to some some level
k beliefs about all the other agents and
these could be different beliefs in each
step and they could be inconsistent so
we're not having we don't require any
consistency of these beliefs
those or we can change from the number
levels forward can change from step to
step the beliefs themselves can change
from step to step and they can be
inconsistent among sellers in the same
step or same seller in different steps
that they don't have to have the same
beliefs and each step then for a market
which has thus elastic and bounded
demand these updates are all monotone
sub strictly sub homogeneous bounded and
stable and therefore they convert to an
equilibrium always so so this is
basically the end of the talk what I
showed you also applies to asynchronous
updates where Tina will measure instead
of step it will measure a pox where an
epic is a period of time where there's
at least one update to each price the
worst case in fact is is best response
so if you have more elaborate beliefs
this converges faster and here are two
questions so first of all can we show
something in the more general setting
games or some tightness I'm certain
interesting types of games and I think
what's perhaps even more interesting is
we allow here completely arbitrary
beliefs that are not updated according
to any information that is being
revealed during this process so in fact
we don't learn anything we just the only
thing we learn is what are the new
prices of course of course that's
information so it would be interesting
to study or to come up with with with a
plausible model of updating beliefs
based on information that is being
revealed through this process of the
market and and to make it more
realistically we will probably need to
assume that the information is noisy so
that we don't know exactly the accuracy
of of the signal but we know it contains
are some amount of
firm a shin the utility functions are
not utility functions here not updated
this is a static situation because the
convergence is is very quick you would
assume that if the market changes at a
much slower rate than the convergence
rate then it would appear to be close to
equilibrium almost all the time yeah
turn this around and away and and look
to see to try to infer something about
the police I'm knowing it apriori given
the way the market is going um yeah I'm
not sure I understand what you mean by
that let's say let's say you're just
monitoring the prices yeah okay and
you've developed all this in the news no
something bad and is it possible to
infer what the police are oh IC IC given
a specific sequence of updates can I try
to infer things like things like that
between sellers yeah okay okay so so
yeah so we're actually assuming here
that each seller there are no coalition
so they're not trying to yeah so that's
what you know is there something you
further relief that then you you can
apply this to a gamer market where that
you can make a statement about oh this
is not behaving well I guess I i I'm not
sure about how to do it algorithmically
but obviously if you're assuming that
each seller is best responding to some
belief and they're changing the price in
a certain way you can you can definitely
try to enumerate over all the beliefs
that they might form and find something
that is consistent with with the change
that there might be more than one
solution for instance so the question I
think it's more like well you look at
what's happening and yeah
sophisticated of the sellers in this
game right huh yeah mm-hmm so you might
try to infer this I'm not sure first of
all it's not clear that there's one one
answer yeah yeah and and right now other
than complete enumeration I can't
immediately think of a better algorithm
but but there but you know it's it's a
good question so it's a good question we
don't know the answer right now yeah
experiments where people face more games
he tried comparing Nash equilibrium to
scalable I don't know the results I know
he's done something of that it basically
said these models feel much better to
the data but this is the nature model
compared to yeah well Nash equilibria in
repeated games are somewhat problematic
right because you have these grim
trigger strategies that can force any
outcome basically to your desire you
know so there seems to be very extensive
experimental evidence that at least in
in settings where that were tested in
the lab this is the way people play
games actually eyes me of this fantasy
game
people are playing where there are some
players who are much more sophisticated
than others in the phone yeah your
theory that says if you someone has a
much deeper belief system the other guys
that they actually do much better in
terms of extract ah in our setting no
because because the whole thing no
matter what the beliefs are in no matter
what levels each of the players has no
matter how deep they look into it
converges very quickly to equilibrium so
even just for best response if
everybody's best responding and one
player is is is is you know doing a very
deep look ahead then they might gain
over this transient but it's a very
short period of time yeah the
equilibrium is independent of that
because it's unique so you're converging
always to the same point but in in more
general games maybe that's a good
question there's a monitor the city for
example if I think that you're thinking
ten levels deep but you're only taking
five levels deep should i do better for
thinking that you're thinking for i mean
uh well the only answer that I have
right now is that best response is the
worst case so we don't know that five
levels are what what is what is maybe
something that I can say about this in
this model basically every player
assumes that they're slightly smarter
than everybody else yes yes so I don't
know it's definitely a natural
assumption for many people the absolute
worst assumption to make when you go
please uh-huh yeah but but this is the
model that we have that each player is
slightly thinks they're slightly smarter
than everybody else because they're
playing at least one step extra reverse
that
Slightly Stoopid on everybody um so
you're below so you have a belief that
everybody else is going to do something
but you're not going to best respond to
that you're actually going to yeah I
don't know how to translate that into a
strategy yeah okay